da in einer stinkenden gas im zürcher
niederdorf brauten sich vor exakt 100
jahren zwei revolutionen zusammen die
eine rief nach dem kommunismus und die
andere recovery bill berry die loni
kalorien
das tönt ziemlich durchgeknallt aber ob
das unsinns gedicht das am 15 februar
1916 im zürcher cabaret voltaire den
dadaismus los trat nicht ähnlich
umwälzen war wie die gedanken die
wladimir iljitsch lenin nur sechs häuser
weiter ausbreitete darüber kann man
völlig debattieren und genau das wollen
wir tun mit zwei sehr klugen köpfen die
viel von sprache und von den großen
gedanken gebäuden des letzten
jahrhunderts verstehen herzlich begrüße
ich im studio den deutschen philosophen
wolfram eilenberger und den
österreichischen schriftsteller raoul
schrott willkommen
1 herren raum schrott sie lieben die
sprache so sehr dass sie das gilgamesch
epos der sumerer die ihn aus der alten
griechen und sogar mehr tausendjährige
liebesgedichte persönliche neu übersetzt
sagen sie uns ist gar dschibril bakri
die ein sprachliches kunstwerk oder ein
jux das ist auch eine zweifel eine sehr
elementare ausdrucksweise dessen was
menschliche emotionen betrifft und was
kommunikation betrifft die da ist noch
nicht nur das laut gedicht erfunden sehr
macht die konkrete poesie erfunden das
typografischen gedicht sondern den
poetry-slam erfunden das nannte zara
damals das dynamische gedicht von der
konventionellen ausdrucksweise das licht
das buddhistische geräusche an
mit diesen geräuschen angereichert wird
es gab das aktions gedicht wo man sich
gymnastik bewegt hat zara hat figuren
mit ganzen plakaten auf denen buchstaben
oder worte standen hat sie auf der bühne
sich gruppieren lassen und wechselnde
aussagen zu formen und das laut gedicht
es im strengen sinne keine drastische
erfindung das gibt es vorläufer die sich
sie haben ja die zum atelier untersucht
4000 jahre zurück hat irgendein sumera
schon so ein bisschen was laut gedichte
riecht immer die dichtung kommt dass der
religion was bei hugo ball mit seinem
magischen bischof dann vielleicht eine
rolle spielen wird
das hat sich sehr langsam von der
religion emanzipiert und alles was
sprachlich evoziert was klang ist wird
von diesen laut gericht natürlich auch
mitgetragen
das heißt die frühesten formen von laut
gedichte sind zaubersprüche die rein
klang magisch auch funktionieren sollen
im unmittelbaren vorfeld da das wurde
das laut gericht praktiziert von
morgenstern wenn sie sowohl von nebel
und es ist aber der entscheidende punkt
dabei ist es das was bei einem laut
gedicht zum vorschein kommt sind klänge
und die einzelnen buchstaben verbinden
wir nach wie vor mit bestimmten
sinnzusammenhänge das heißt wenn wir uns
hier rechts eine wolke vorstellen
wollten ähnliches gebilde links ein
schattiges gebilde und ich legen zwei
monate vor und bitte dies bitte sie
diese beiden worte zuzuordnen das eine
ist mein land das andere ist das völlig
klar was wir zu organisieren ästhetische
erfahrungen sind das heißt auch die
gehirnforschung kann nachweisen dass
bestimmte biologische disposition und
bestimmte wahrnehmungsweisen mit
bestimmten klängen verbunden sind war es
die werbung heute in großem maße
ausnutzten
aufgrund dieser klanglichen
eigenschaften werden die ganzen trade
marks von werbe namen des autonomen
konzipiert das haben wir uns später noch
an also ist nicht einfach sinnlose
geplapper da steckt viel dahinter das
irgendwie heraus wolfram eilenberger sie
sind als chefredaktor des deutschen
philosophie magazins bekannt als einer
der begnadetsten erklärer und kenner
komplexer gedankengebäude zählen sie
jetzt das was diese gut ein dutzend
männer und frauen in cabaret voltaire
gemacht haben und die leute selbst zu
den innovatoren der geistesgeschichte
das würde ich schon sagen
sophie nennt man sowas ein ereignis ein
ereignis ist etwas das unsere gesamte
welt wahrnehmen umstellt dass es uns
eine neue weise gibt die welt zu
betrachten und in dem sie dann würde ich
sagen dass da eine neue ganze welt sicht
ermöglicht hatte eine weltsicht die uns
bis heute prägt ich denke wir bewegen
uns in vielen werbe ästhetik aber auch
in der popkultur in der spur von data
und wenn man sagt wo lag da ein anfang
dann würde ich schon sagen in zürich am
5 februar da ist was ganz besonderes
passiert der spießbürger den schon fast
nicht mehr gibt oder wie alle wenn wir
entstand die schlaue sind sagt
vielleicht schon mal na ja das könnte
ich auch gerade beim beben in bam das
ist nicht kunst kommt von können und da
muss man nichts können was antworten sie
auf solche einwände
da ich würde sagen eine was eine aussage
bedeutet ist vor dem hintergrund dieser
aussage zu bewerten da hintergrund
dieser aussage ist eine sprachkritik
eine kritik an der ideologie an der
konstellation dieser jahre und das waren
kriegsjahre es war eine extremsituation
es waren jahre in denen viele
philosophien und auch poetischen zu
kriegs treibenden ideologien geworden
sind das heißt da das zunächst mal eine
entzugs figur von einer gewalttätigen
form der sprache abstand zu nehmen und
sehen welche gewalt sprache hervorruft
gerade die gewalt der dichtung gerade
die gewalt der dichtung und die gewalt
der philosophie das waren ja alles
philosophisch gebildete menschen
insofern ist das nicht einfach eine
unsinns intervention sondern etwas sehr
gezieltes er schaut sie haben ihre ganze
erste laufbahn phasen die promotion und
die habilitation im thema data gewidmet
aus liebe aus leidenschaft oder anderen
können für mich war es der erste
bekanntschaft mit dem schreiben wie man
das schreiben lernt was schreiben soll
das war auch meine erste bekanntschaften
mit dichtern also ich konnte noch den
letzten der ersten kennenlernen philipp
oder zusammen mit dem briten das erste
realistische manifest geschrieben haben
was dabei ist in zürich präsent war ganz
gut in genf präsent war schon alle
freundlich da war da mit 93 und das war
für mich der erste handschlag mit deinem
leben den dichter und welche als an da
hat sie das durchfahren aber ist so in
einem richtigen dichter was drin jetzt
sind sie auch allen dingen weil man ja
wissen wollte wo mit kochen die hier mit
dieser portion humor mit dieser portion
ironie mit vor allen dingen der
hinterfragung von einem selbst also
diese sich nicht ernst nehmen und
gleichzeitig dieses oszillieren zwischen
verschiedenen positionen auf eine
haltung die ich damals etwas
existenzialistisches verstanden habe
weil sie das absurde unserer fiktionen
in den vordergrund kehrt uns bewusst
macht dass all das was wir glauben all
das was wir sind all das was wir suchen
letztlich konstruktionen sind des
menschlichen aufgrund verschiedener
perspektiven und das hat mich sehr
fasziniert was er hat von frey
geistigkeit war nicht mehr von literatur
erwartet habe dass ich dann gemerkt da
sind eine tortur betrieb besteht genau
so dass konformisten und spielt aber
aber aber diese art von lebendigkeit
kennenzulernen war etwas für mich
menschlich wichtiges sich mit den texten
auseinanderzusetzen in ihrer vielfalt
und ihrer komplexität wird das äußerst
spannendes eine ganze periode entdecken
zu können bei der man heute nacht
nämlich dass den besten zwei jahre in
tirol waren die aber doch am scheideweg
behinderten diese beiden jahre zwischen
das haben sie dann fertig realisation
gepackt und das konnte man so richtig
ausrollen und was mich da was mich dabei
auch fasziniert hat war diese gruppe die
aus lauter individuen bestand und ein
lockerer verbund die der aus
individualität dann doch etwas größeres
gemacht hat und das war etwas was ich
mir als literat immer gewünscht hätte
diese art von kundenbindung nutzen ich
glaube was für junge menschen und für
menschen die auch in der literatur und
philosophie ihren anfang suchen
besonders interessant ist dass da auch
ein
hat abrissbirne ist man kommt dann so
ein wissens gebäude und eine system
alles ist schon vorformatiert alles ist
schon gedacht und dann ist diese gruppe
von menschen die reißen das alles nieder
mit dem was unsinn scheint und man hat
dann selber als anfänger das gefühl ein
freiraum zu haben und dieser freiraum
diese befreiungsaktion des dollars ist
glaube ich eine ganz entscheidender
punkt der damals wirksamer und der
eigentlich heute immer noch wirksam ist
das was vernunft scheint erstmal ganz
grundsätzlich in frage zu stellen um
selbst zu einer stimme finden was ist
das was sie angezogen hat
interessanterweise auch sie als junger
wissenschaftler bei der doktorarbeit
haben dabei auf den rabatten auf papas
der grund ich habe mich sehr früh für
den unsinn im sinn interessiert in der
philosophie und hast die narren gestalt
und der karneval eben ganz wichtig und
die da ist dann sind eben philosophisch
gebildete dichter gewesen denen ist ein
zuviel an vernunft gab und das hat mich
sehr interessiert wie man gegen vernunft
systeme interveniert und neue freiräume
schafft das macht der karneval das macht
auch sokrates und es macht eben auch die
datei ist das heißt die philosophie es
eben nicht nur ein system sondern ist
oftmals ein anti system ein freiraum
schaffen und das war das was mich damals
und heute noch interessiert daran das
wollen wir mit zwei leuten wir ihnen
dann noch ganz genau wissen der aufstand
gegen die vernunft der gutes oder auch
ins elend führen kann zuerst möchte ich
jetzt die frage anpacken mal warum
entstand da da war es eine flucht aus
der zeit aus einer schrecklichen zeit
damals natürlich erster weltkrieg was
hat diese strömung in zürich ausgelöst
und um jene jahre des ersten weltkriegs
zwischen 14 und 19 18 etwas zu
vergegenwärtigen damit wir die sache
nicht nur kognitiv besprechen sondern
bisschen vielleicht etwas davon spüren
habe ich einen kurzen ausschnitt aus dem
tollen film das prinzip da mitgebracht
dass wir uns gleich nach unseren
gesprächen der sternstunde kunst an ihr
zeigen hier noch einmal auf eine ganz
gekürzte ab eine aufschlussreiche minute
die zeigt wie
mit da da losgehen warum wurde vor 100
jahren die kunst so grundlegend
umgekrempelt
was brachte künstler wie zum beispiel
marcel duchamp der noch 1910 solche
bilder malte dazu will die später
installationen wie diese zu machen
wie aller revolutionen reifte auf die
kunst revolution über eine längere zeit
seit dem ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts
damals änderte sich das leben der
menschen in nur wenigen jahrzehnten so
schnell wie nie zuvor
in wandel gerät das ganze welt bild der
soziale und politische umbruch war in
vollem gange
doch die kunst war in großen und ganzen
immer noch von alten mustern geprägt es
gab klare gattungen skulptur malerei
die kunst war etwas wertvolles sie
hingen museen in salon in bürgerlichen
wohnzimmer die kunst wollte das schöne
und wahre sein abbild des lebens das
vermochte die fotografie mittlerweile
nicht schlechter
[Musik]
so fing die kunst an nach einem neuen
sinn nach neuen inhalten und formen zu
suchen
das loslösen von figurativen von öl und
leinwand begann
doch das waren bloß die ersten schritte
erst da da sprengte definitiv die alten
muster
es passierte während des ersten
weltkrieges für die menschen damals war
es der weltuntergang völker schlachteten
sich gegenseitig ab mit allen
errungenschaften des technischen
fortschritts 17 millionen menschen
starben
[Musik]
dazu millionen werden die menschen auf
den schlachtfeldern europas er hingeht
zu tun zuhauf strömen emigranten auch in
die schweiz sind die schweiz von der
nada gründer hugo ball sagt die sie sei
gewesen wie ein vogelkäfig umgeben von
rollenden löwen da staunt sie dass das
eine der verrücktesten revolutionen in
der braven gutbürgerlichen schweiz
nein das ist eigentlich eine sehr nahe
liegende entwicklung denn es ist ja so
die sprachen von einer flucht da da
sucht es waren ja alles flüchtlinge
teilweise kriegsflüchtlinge herr pfarrer
aus rumänien herr ball aus berlin
und das sind alles menschen die auch
daran verzweifelt sind wie die systeme
die sie selbst als denker hochgehalten
haben zu einer ideologischen verengung
führten das heißt sie sind buchstäblich
an ihrer eigenen bildung verzweifelt da
spielt natürlich auch die dichtung eine
wesentliche rolle denken sie an die
romantik die den national gedanken so
sehr hoch gehalten hat und die dichter
waren gleichsam die paradigmatischen
vertreter des nationalen und im jahre
1919 20 gab seine ganze ideologie die
dann im namen von goethe im namen von
schiller im namen von kant den weltkrieg
rechtfertigte oder in frankreich im
namen der großen französischen denker
den weltkrieg rechtfertigte und diese
verzweiflung führte dann zu einer
verzweiflung an der sprache selbst mit
der sprache die wir haben können wir
nicht mehr arbeiten also müssen wir die
sprache selbst zerstören instruieren ad
absurdum führen und das ist der
dadaistische einsatz dieser exilanten in
zürich oder zumindest ein wesentlicher
aspekt davon hat für sie der ort wo
sowas entsteht sehr viel zu tun mit dem
was entsteht fall bringen weil war ein
psychischen zerrspiegel war für die
damalige gesellschaft das heißt wenn man
dieses argument des moralischen schocks
in einem weiteren konzentrischen kreis
bearbeitet und heißt es da da war die
erste erfahrung mit der medialen
materiellen modernen welt seine konzepte
hatte es vom futurismus übernommen
mit seiner reinigung des technischen der
maschine die die die erkundung der
menschlichen abgründe kam aus dem
expressionismus und die die die die
vorstellung dass sprache aktiv ii ziell
und symbolisches kam vor allen dingen
vom französischen symbolismus
dazu kam das was man in berlin die
großstadt erfahrung nannte berlins in
höhe von 20 30 jahren millionenstadt
geworden die die erfahrung der
geschwindigkeit der masse also da war
plötzlich diese welt die wir heute für
gegeben setzen die wir damals frisch da
aber zuerst war vergleichsweise klein
und das ist der entscheidende punkt dann
durch dieses zürich oder durch diese
schweiz die die da ist ein damals als
engstirnig dumpf empfunden haben in
einem land wo es auch verkleinerungen
endet mit dem kaffee und gipfeli und so
weiter also in dieser puppenstube
eingesperrt zu sein weil das ja alles
auch kriegsflüchtlinge waren die nicht
eingezogen werden wollten die sich hier
stellungs kommission unterziehen mussten
die nur ein bisschen davon profitieren
konnten dass die sympathien der
damaligen schweizer seite frankreichs
denn auf seiten der pickel heutigen
deutschen lagen all das hat das dazu
geführt dass sodass hier plötzlich eine
enge da war man versucht hat in diesen
gegenüber von von chronik der sperr
links gaster hinaus zum großstädtischen
sich zu verorten und wie diese verortung
stattzufinden habe diese sucht bewegung
das machte da der vor allen dingen in
den ersten jahren also beißt da
unpolitisch sein musste weil er die hier
bespitzelt worden sind und weil die es
gar nicht hätten wagen können offen
gegen den krieg offen politische
positionen zu vertreten und werden sie
einfach ausgewiesen worden
ich glaube dass da noch ganz wichtig ist
wie sprechen davon dass ein weltbild
zusammengebrochen ist mit dem zweiten
weltkrieg das ist natürlich politisch
und weltanschaulich richtig aber es ist
noch mehr passiert in dieser zeit ist es
auch naturwissenschaftlich und
psychologisch ein weltbild
zusammengebrochen
wir haben freut die feier des traums des
irrationalen auch die bedeutung des
kindes das sehr wichtig wurde für da und
wir haben natürlich zum beispiel albert
einstein oder
107 mit der relativitätstheorie das
heißt das denken über raum und zeit
veränderte sich ganz grundlegend und das
sehen sie alle da ist es schon collagen
das raum und zeit in ein neues
verhältnis treten
und wir haben natürlich ein nietzsche
der damals unter der lebensphilosophie
eine umwertung aller werte forderte und
diese drei konstellation denke ich ist
eine ganz wichtige kraftfelder einmal
die feier des irrationalen einmal raum
und zeit werden neue empfunden und
einmal das was wir dann
lebensphilosophie nannten das heißt das
prinzip des lebens gegen das prinzip der
vernunft und da entsteht ein kraftfeld
mit dem alle diese da da ist auch
vertraut waren aus ihrer prägung diese
verachtung ein bisschen für die exil
heimat für die puppenstube geht auch
hervor glaube ich aus dem setzen des
dabei ist ein richard ösen beck der die
schweiz ein land von kropp menschen und
joghurt fanatikern nannte aber offenbar
auch unter joghurt fanatik am kamm kann
großes entstehen
das waren ja auch alles bürgersöhne
bürgersöhne die zur flucht gezwungen
waren
so dient der schweiz dann ein
bürgerliches idel wiederfanden sozusagen
den letzten rest der heilen welt so
stelle ich mir das zumindest vor
und ich kann mir vorstellen dass das
auch eine große aggression gegen sich
selbst von seiten der da ist als auch
gegen das milieu hervorgeht und das ist
da ja auch es ist ja eine große
aggression gegen alles bestehende das
was in den frühen texten die sie ja
natürlich beziehen immer wieder auf doch
ist das französische wort in me und wie
lange michael eckel abscheu aber vor
allen dingen einen entfremdung zustand
beschreibt zwischen der großen weiten
großstadt welt in den krieg zieht
zwischen der kleinen parasitären schweiz
die im schrebergarten existiert und
diesen kosmopolitischen existenzen die
laute mehrfach begabungen waren die alle
philosophen waren schriftsteller in
mehreren sprachen sprachen sowohl
künstlerisch malerisch musikalisch wie
poetisch arbeiteten die versucht haben
in dieser entfremdung einem punkt zu
finden sondern ein problem
oder besser gesagt eine haltung zu
finden wie man dieser modernen welt
begegnen kann eine der kürzesten
definition und was dabei ist stammt vom
höchsten berg der sorgt da da war der
versuch die intensivste
und zugleich die primitivste annäherung
an die umwelt herzustellen sie also
nicht für gegeben zu setzen sondern
sondern sondern der versuch in dieser
technisierten totalitären und vor allen
dingen konformen politisch korrekten
welt die alles geschluckt hat auch keine
abweichenden aussagen zunächst die den
spielraum des individuellen denn wir
heute für gegeben setzen noch gar nicht
kannte da das individuelle zu behaupten
um einen punkt zu finden nun zwischen
und das ist das entscheidende für mich
was ich dann wieder mit der narrenfigur
trifft oder über über schneider aus den
verschiedensten philosophischen systemen
aus den verschiedensten ästhetischen
systemen aus den verschiedensten
naturwissenschaftlichen geschichtlichen
traditionellen systemen immer wieder
schnittpunkte zu finden die vorläufig
dass ich definieren
in seinem gegenüber zu welt um sich ihr
an verwandeln zu können das heißt
material auf der welt zu nehmen die
unzugänglich ist die technisierte ist
die story ist um sie zu meinem zu machen
gleichzeitig aber auch sie durch meine
eigene aussage zu verändern das heißt da
da ist weniger ein kunstwollen als eine
haltung also ein etat des prix der sich
versucht in kunst zu realisieren um sich
selbst zu realisieren
ich glaub ich noch was ganz wichtiges
gesagt aus mir sehr wichtig sie haben
einen möglichst unmittelbaren zugang zu
einer als verstellt empfunden
wirklichkeit und denken sie was ein kind
macht dass zb eine apfelsine oder ein
glas sieht sagt da es ist einfach nur da
ich suche den unmittelbaren zugang zur
wirklichkeit und das war eben auch das
gefühl dass die sprache selbst die
sprache wie sie multimedial in der
propaganda des weltkriegs verhindert
keinen zugang zur wirklichkeit mehr
ermöglicht und dann wurde eben gedacht
wir gehen zusagen zurück an den anfang
wir suchen eine art adam ist eine ur
sprache eine kinder sprache und das sind
ja die erste lautet dieser laut gedichte
eigentlich durch die sprachen durch
einen neuen zugang zu dem zu finden was
man wirklichkeit hätte nennen wollen
es war ja ein unglaublicher zufall der
auch zeigt dass die puppenstube nicht
nur puppenstube war die schweiz sondern
eben auch hort
menschen mit politischen ansichten also
ein ort der freiheit man doch auch mal
unglaublicher zufall dieses cabaret
voltaire steht bis heute kann man jeden
tag daran vorbeigehen wenn man in zürich
wohnt an der spiegelgasse 16 häuser
weiter spiegel zitiert sind wohnt linien
mit seiner frau der die welt dann auf
andere weise umgewälzt hatten die
dadaisten mit politik irgendwas am hut
später nach dem ende des ersten
weltkrieges in berlin als es um die
weimarer republik gegen aber ansonsten
weder in paris noch in hannover noch in
köln noch in zürich statt politik im
vordergrund in zürich wäre es im
vordergrund gestanden wenn es
möglichkeiten gegeben hätte sie offen zu
präsentieren da sie aber bespitzelt
worden sind und sie auch offen ihr
einverständnis erklären mussten haider
eröffnungen und ist cabaret voltaire
sich nicht politisch zu betätigen keine
politischen aussagen zu treffen sondern
sich auf das rein künstlerische
ästhetische literarische zu beschränken
war das also nie richtig thema
da wurde erst richtig provokant 19 19 an
der zahl von kaufleuten wo dann die
gefahren nicht mehr wahr abgeschoben zu
werden man nicht an der zugang zu europa
wieder frei war wo die mitarbeiter der
anstalt und damit 1000 da ist er dann
richtig zum ersten mal auf die bühne
selbstbewusst auf die bühne getreten
während es vorher sich versuchten in den
verschiedensten traditionen irgendwie zu
konfigurieren das heißt da das zu meinen
nicht nur der anbruch des neuen sondern
zum haben dann auch die abrechnung oder
das bilanzieren des bisherigen
bildungsbürgertums um dabei traditionen
zu entdecken rand phänomene sozusagen
der weltliteratur aus denen sich dieses
neue unschuldige spontaneität suchende
mit dem absurden sich beschäftigende mit
dem widersprüchlichen arbeitende ich zu
konfigurieren und das ging in
chinesische märchen hinein das ging in
traditionen wie sie selber nannten sie
haben einen abend gemacht für god eater
und für [ __ ]
das heißt da sind technologische die
karte vorgelesen wurden von aborigines
in australien über afrikanische oder
neuseeländische genitiv ist sozusagen
orale poesie der indigenen völker dort
dort dann haben die aus albrecht dürers
tagebuch vorgelesen von albertus ägidius
nachts böhme die mystiker nostradamus
professoren als all das was irgendwie
diese unschuld oder fahrrad das anders
genannt der kam in dieser puppenstube
hier zu einer krise zu einer krise und
hat dann gesagt er wäre hätte dann einen
mystischen punkt gefunden der jedoch
nicht religiös gewesen wäre sondern rein
zerebraler natur also das war irgendwie
das verlangen danach einen einen punkt
zu finden der unschuld mit
unmittelbarkeit mit welthaltigkeit
folgen mit leben in verbindung mit einem
long mit zahlen dass das schlägt also
aus 1000 blüten das sind für mich
nachher urwald der formen und so haben
auch gesagt es war die suche nach neuer
unschuld
schauen wir uns noch mal den anfang an
the very beginnen an diesem fünften
februar vor 100 jahren den wir jetzt
auch sozusagen begehen fing es an mit
einer art blech bischof der auf die
bühne tritt hugo ball
in diesem kostüm woher daneben dass
barry baum zu sagen
erklären sie uns was sollte dieses
dieses blech höheren bischofs kostümen
also ich glaube dass man drei dinge sehr
wichtig erstmals ist ein bischof das ist
schon eine veräppelung einer einer
ehrenvollen religiösen gestalt es ist
ein bischof der in einer art
aluminiumhülle ist da sehen sie dieses
futuristische und das neu daran
und natürlich ganz wichtig dass wird
vergessen es ist ja im februar das heißt
es eine karnevalszeit und die
verhohnepiepelung des bischofs als
bischof ist ein ganz zentrales element
jeder karnevalisten feiern
so kann man also sehen dass hier seien
elemente des karnevals mit elementen des
futurismus und natürlich einer neuen
richtung vermengt werden und das hat mir
auch ganz wichtig was sie sagen da hat
er ist natürlich das was man ein spiel
so eine postmoderne eine sind kritische
form ist die sich alle möglichen formen
bedient und darin einen freiraum zu
suchen das heißt der neue anfang wusste
sich als unmöglich und hat dann aus
verschiedenen formen
aber das ist eine szene wie sie
wahrscheinlich in mittelalterlichen
darstellung aus dem karneval da werden
sie ganz ähnliche abbildungen finden
ich würde also sagen es gibt doch einen
ganz ganz starken bezug zu dieser welt
auf dem kopf
die der karneval zu dieser zeit immer
auch jährlich in ganz europa gefeiert
hat und vor allen dingen was ist noch
zusätzliches bischof von nadel sind
insofern verwandt was die narren mütze
die parodie des bischofs sieht es mit
seinen beiden spitzen und das was hugo
ball mehrfach gemacht und ist immer
wieder narren figuren auf die bühne zu
stellen die sich krug oder grüne gaukler
wo wärmenden denn der ränder der fantast
lametta so lauter karnevals figuren
variete figuren die bis hin zu einer
blume von schwitters gehen ab der gute
kasper ist tot also dieses dieses wissen
darum dass die unschuld des menschlichen
oder das menschliche das humane ansicht
dass sich fern jeder systematik in
narren und im schellen äußert im shell
mit seiner kritischen form indem er den
ganzen eulenspiegel figuren all das der
menschlichen rationalität gegenüber hält
also das ist das zumindest für mich sind
das die galionsfiguren da das in denen
das humane seinen seinen schönsten
ausdruck findet seinen unschuldigsten
ausdruck aber auch seinen fixen und
seinen provokantesten ausdruck der sich
gesellschaftlich randständig zeigt und
bis hin zu den ganzen hochstapler
figuren geht die berner dann heraus
arbeitet wo dass ich quasi position in
einer gesellschaft sucht die hoch ist
sehr konformistischen totalitär geprägt
von kapitalismus und
wirtschaftsliberalismus von schieber
thum von von von all den formen die wir
heute auch bei den banken konstatieren
und die sich da eine gesellschaftliche
position sucht die noch irgendeine art
von spielraum und ellenbogenfreiheit
erlaubt um dieses
menschlich grobe unfassbar ist gibt
sicherlich noch einen ganz wichtigen
vorbei es gibt natürlich die narrenfigur
die sich als nachweis als weiß danach
aber es gibt natürlich auch noch eine
andere utopie der unschuld und das ist
das kind das kind ist noch gar nicht so
vergesellschaftet dass es dieses ganze
lügenspiel mit machen kann
und natürlich ist da da ist er in 1 1
ein wort für ein schaukelpferd bei
gittern natürlich gibt es so einen
russischen aspekt dass im kind noch eine
reinheit und auch in der kinder sprache
gefunden werden kann
die sowas erzeugt was wir vielleicht
heute authentizität nennen würden also
eine nicht verstellt und nur weil er die
modernen banken ins spiel geredet adel
hier
und wenn wir gesagt haben das ist
entstanden zur zeit des ersten
weltkriegs eine antwort losigkeit dem
bildungsbürger sagen kann mit meinem
goethe ist das entstanden was nicht ist
kann man auch ein vergleich machen gibt
heute wieder ähnliche befindlichkeiten
keine antworten auf die
herausforderungen der zukunft sind wir
wieder ein bisschen in dabei ist dieser
ausgangslage also wenn sich die schweiz
weiter so herr gegen alles abschottet
glaube ich dann haben wir bald wieder
ein cabaret voltaire hat sich die lage
um die schweizer unsere kritische wurden
flüchtlingen ausgesprochen schmal gibt
es natürlich weil sie auch nach dem
politischen einsatz fragen richtig vorm
das manifest eigentlich eine politische
gattung es gibt die idee einer bewegung
die auch eine sehr politische sache ist
und denken sie an occupy wallstreet
beispielsweise das ist eine bewegung die
gar nichts fordert die eigentlich nur
interveniert die keine forderung
aufstellt und die genau wie da an ganz
verschiedenen orten weltweit aufblüht
und dann wieder zu verschwinden also das
schicksal von solchen bewegungen die
selbst gar nichts fordern sondern nur
intervenieren ist eben dass sie nur ein
anfang sind und diese anfangs strahlt
einen ganz verschiedene kunstraum und
wenn ich es richtig sehe war es ja bei
da so sein kurzes aufblitzen
das dann in syrien ismus in ganz
verschiedene formen ging und so was
sieht man immer wieder ich würde sagen
das nächste was dem kommt das natürlich
keine politische form sondern politisch
hat also occupy wall street eine
intervention keine forderung kein
programm und ein frühling getanzt und
jetzt wieder wegschauen wir haben ein
kunstwerk an aber aber vorher noch weil
das wirklich eine interessante frage von
heute aus gesehen ist weiter aus klarer
dass der komfort um
es muss damals sehr präsent waren alles
geschluckt hat dieses buch mäßig an die
front marschieren
wer zu hause alles hungert und die
wirtschaft alles dominiert auch noch
verkörpert durch die jeweiligen
monarchen
aber es ist die frage ist dieser
totalitarismus heute nicht in weitaus
größerem maße vorhanden ohne also
bewusst ist
das heißt die unterordnung unter einen
wirtschaftsliberalismus bei der die
politik letztlich sich zurückzieht bei
dem dass autos heute mir schon sagen
dass ich mich an schnallen muss und das
und das und das machen muss wohl jede
art von eigenverantwortung abgegeben
wird an eine standardisierte
computertechnik bei der wenn ich irgend
eine reklamation habe ich in der
warteschleife london sagen das kann man
nicht machen dass der computer des sohns
um ok also ist diese art von
konformismus und totalitarismus heute
nicht weitaus stärker ohne dass wir uns
aber seiner negativen seiten bewusst
sind dort wo aber diese totalitarismen
aufgetreten sind wie beispielsweise in
polen bei der sogenannten orangen
bewegung da kann da der ukrainische in
der ukraine aber dann in polen den in
den in den 18
da habt ihr da ist also in den einsatz
der also da hat das da ist sich also
dieses behaupten des menschlichen in
seiner in seiner wichtigkeit eine 1 1
potenzial ein politisches ein
provokantes potenzial von dem ich heute
nicht wüsste wie dieses provokante
potenzial in seiner humanität darstellen
ich kann provokant sein da muss ich
äußerst rechts sein dann bin ich
provokant aber aber wo aber dieses
betonen des humanen heute in einer
gesellschaft die die quasi
standardisiertes und sich freiwillig
standardisiert also wenn sie wenn sie
sagen uns gibt vielleicht jetzt einen
versteckten totalitarismus dazu so sanft
ist dass man nicht wirklich direkt so
viel stoff und damals haben die die
sprache verweigerten die war schmutzig
wie die münze an der die die daten
abgegriffen henze aber man kann nur
einmal die sprache was ein
schriftsteller wie die künstler wie sie
was kann er heute noch mit sprache
machen dieser schock
diese verzückung auch die haben die
praktizierte da leisten das kann man
nichts manchmal was kann man heute wie
reden oder schreiben sie an wenn sie
gegen solchen totalitarismus anschreiben
möchten ist eine gute frage habe ich
keine antwort kann ich ja kein modell
man könnte sagen tragischerweise hat
eben da da diese interventionen die ist
nur einmal gab den raum jetzt auch sehr
sehr eng gemacht also was will man denn
jetzt noch tun das ist ja sein
grundsätzliches problem der künstler der
heutigen zeit die sich kein außen der
kunst mehr finden und all die form die
super sie fahren sind in die marktlogik
mittlerweile integriert und da
insbesondere das eine reine werbe logik
geworden aber ich denke was da eben ja
auch richtig schön dieses sprachen von
der betonung des humanen und ich finde
ich ganz wichtig es ist natürlich auch
ein ganz ehrliche ausdruck einer
ratlosigkeit eure sprache taugt nicht
mehr
aber wir haben keine augen und das ist
eine figur die man in der philosophie
oft mit der skepsis verbindet ihr habt
eine behauptung ich glaube nicht dass
das stimmt ich habe aber keine bessere
und dann gibt es drei versionen die das
skeptischer wählen kann er schweigt er
stammelt oder er geht zur aktion über
und in gewisser weise kann man sagen da
da stammelte und ging zur aktion über
und die eher mystische die ja noch
skeptischer brillantes eben dann das
schweigen dass das ist toll schweigen
stammen oder handeln das nehme ich
nachher wieder auf auch in bezug auf
heute ich wollte noch an einem kart wenn
sie sagen man kann es nicht neu erfinden
an gewisse werke von joseph beuys denken
hinter sind man sich dann was das war
mit diesem berühmten kunstwerk das
marcel duchamp 19 17 glaube ich an einer
ausstellung in new york zeigen wollte
war noch eine ausstellung von
fortschrittlichen könnten society auf
independent artists er hat ein paar
genommen dass abbott iron works in new
york gekauft hat habe es nur hingestellt
und bisschen nach oben gedreht und
gesagt das ist kunst und selbst diese
fortschrittlichen aussteller sagten ist
keine kunst
nur schon weil du es nicht selber
gemacht hast dann das kunst sein wenn es
im handel gekauft hat die frage was
kunst definieren
als ästhetisches objekt ist es in seiner
fremdheit ein kunstobjekt gleichzeitig
war ein produkt der masse und des bandes
und der versucht beides über
einzubringen nämlich eine technisierte
umwelt mit ihren formen für etwas
ästhetisches zurück zu erklären dass aus
menschlichem design kommt das also
zeugnis von menschliche kreativität es
um es dann mit dem urin in verbindung zu
bringen mit den kassen mit den
primitivsten abscheidung produkt des
menschen
da steckt schon sehr viel von data is
tischen denken drinnen waren es auf der
einen seite die ratio versucht
zurückzudrängen zugunsten des
irrationalen das chaotische dass das
experimentelle des menschen kunst das
richtig ab scheidung krankheit
herauszuarbeiten und vor allen dingen
sich aus diesem technisierten chrysler
was herauszuholen was ich wieder so
etwas menschliches individuelles
reklamieren kann also das wäre wäre wer
eines dieser symboliken wobei der
entscheidende punkt aber zu heute da es
gut wenn damien hirst einen einen hai in
aspik biest oder tracey emin ihr bett
aus stellt dann sind das alles ähnliche
form und nur was der unterschied von
damals zu heute ist damals haben sie
sich selber nicht ernst genommen das war
kein kein keine narzisstischen
selbstdarstellung sondern das war auch
selbstironie die haben sich also selber
dafür also nicht zum künstlern erklärt
sondern zu dilettanten da sollte ich die
sowieso fragen iran die witzig lustig
oder namen die sich doch auch sehr ich
glaube das ist ich würde hoffen
und dass zeugen ja auch die
schriftstücke dass ein gesundes maß an
selbstdisziplin weil es ja noch den
bürgerlichen habitus an diesen menschen
gab die hatten noch die alte künstler
idee wussten sich dass sie das begehren
in sich haben wussten aber auch dass es
nicht mehr möglich ist aber hier sehen
sie natürlich auch erstmal die
umstellung von geist auf leib ja das
denken wird zum pinkeln und natürlich
gab es in dieser zeit zum beispiel john
juli als als kunst philosophie in
amerika der gesagt hat wir stellen wie
kunst ins museum aufs podest um sie zu
vermeiden
und wir müssen die kunst wieder zurück
in den alltag holen und auch das mein
ich war eine ganz starke
strömung damals dass man die kunst aus
dem museum in den alltag integrieren
wollte und was gibt es ein tägliches als
das pinkeln das heißt die idee dass da
auch leben und kunst wieder vereinen
wollte die dann später sehr sehr wichtig
wurde die die widmann auch schon in
solchen objekten die ja eigentlich alte
kurz die profanisierung könnte man sagen
das ist auch kunst später sagt dann der
da ist der philosoph paul feyerabend ich
finde so viele wenn ich das geschirr
spülen
auch das ist diese idee das denken und
leben ganz ganz eng zusammen
gleichzeitig aber könnte man auch sagen
dass die formen die da in der bildenden
kunst betrieben das zufallsprinzip das
aber auch beim schreiben gilt die
collage die sich entweder material aus
der welt holt um sie zum eigenen
ausdrucksmittel zu machen oder aber die
welt so verändert wie den total collagen
von max ernst wo man gar nicht mehr die
überschneidungen merkt dass wo man die
welt draußen sich von selbst verändern
lässt all das sind an verwandlungen im
sinne von von vielleicht ovids
metamorphosen sich in diese welt hinein
zu verwandeln sich ihr an zu verwandeln
sie in sich zu verwandeln
in diesem sinne eben von hülsenbeck als
da der versucht die intensivste und
primitivste form der annäherung an die
umwelt herzustellen meine herren man
spürt und das gefällt mir gut wie sie
mit leidenschaft sympathie faszination
von data und dadaismus reden ich bringe
jetzt doch in diese philosophisch ernste
frage ob es nicht sein könnte dass die
revolte gegen jede vernunft dann auch
wiederum zwingend ins nichts führt und
schlimmes produziert droht der
nihilismus hinter dem bereich also es
gibt ganz klar den idealismus verdacht
er auch gegen da da erhoben wurde teilen
von der bürgerlichen kampanischen
philosophie dass sie gar nichts
entgegenzusetzen hat den kampf machen
die nicht nur eine wahrheit nicht weil
sind alles dienste geprägte neu cantina
damals das heute man vielleicht dazu
sagen war die philosophie in einer sehr
schwachen position
die akademische philosophie war eine
schul philosophie die nur über den neu
kann tennis muss liefern sehr sehr
unproduktiv war in dieser zeit kennt das
ist der ernst reuter auf den alles
zurückgelassen
wann hören natürlich noch ein echo von
nietzsche
die promovierte über ball und da gibt es
dir das ist doch irgendwie klar
erklärbar aber natürlich war es auch
politisch respekt später wurden
natürlich die ganzen avantgarde
strömungen auch aus kann der
kommunistischen seite oder von der
faschistischen seite in gewisser weise
wurde vorgeworfen dass sie auch nicht es
muss sein dass sich nichts zu bieten
haben keine visionen der gesellschaft
keine werte nach denen sie sich richten
musste
und natürlich muss man sagen die ganzen
avantgarde strömung wenn man sie als
interventionen als ausdruck der rat und
sprachlosigkeit versteht haben diesen
hang zum nil ist muss es dann aber
wichtig wie man sie versteht ich würde
da eher wie ein eisbrecher in einem
vereisten umgebung sehen der eine
fahrrinne aufmacht von der dann wieder
neue werte entstehen können so weit
kamen die jungs jetzt nicht aber die
idee war nicht dass man keine werte
haben muss sondern dass man die die
grade regieren dass die unbrauchbar
geworden also peter sloterdijk in seiner
kritik der zynischen vernunft geht so
weit dass er über einen anderen bestens
erinnern den sie erwähnt haben sagt die
tiere sloterdijk wo alles inhaltliche
nicht mehr zählt bleibt nur ein
augenblick der verzweifelten intensität
ein selbstmörder selbstbewusstsein übrig
das mit allem man durch ist das ist
existenz als sein zum tode
herz was der schweiz heisst das fand
hierzu hat geschwafelt habe ich gesagt
ja also das was die dadaisten damals
gesagt hätten werden dass die
philosophie die verschiedensten begriffs
gebäude aufbaut und sie versucht der
irakisch schwer zu konstruieren um auf
bestimmte perspektiven zu kommen dass
all diese perspektiven etwas für sich
haben das aber nie über eingehen das
heißt wenn sie sie ja philosophische
tradition und bezogen hätten und die
haben sie mal sehen den hintergrund
gestellt
das war also zum einen wo ringer mit
seinen als ob konstruktionen den man
heute als philosophischen
konstruktivismus auslegen würde das
bewusstsein dass unsere sprache auf
metaphern beruht dass wir in
assoziationen denke dass wir alles mit
allem vergleichen
dass die sind konstruktionen die wir
haben auf analogien aufgebaut sind
auf der anderen seite ist er als das war
damit nihilismus habe ich glaube ich
lässt sich da dann nur nur nur als
oberflächen phänomen in verbindung
bringen es hat eher was mit anarchismus
zu tun aber anarchismus im klassischen
sinn dass es nicht ein oberstes prinzip
gibt dem sich alle anderen und
sondern mehrere prinzipien je nach
situation dass die verschiedensten
dietrich gibt um die verschiedensten
verschlossenen türen zu öffnen dass sie
aber alle irgendwo hin führen ohne dass
das ein großes labyrinth des
menschlichen interessantes jedoch dass
die da ist was den verschiedensten
traditionen aus den verschiedensten
ländern aus den verschiedensten
philosophie nachkamen und dass da der
letztlich das privileg der jugend ist
diese phase dieses spontane dieses das
negative und das positive zu behalten
das aber dann nach einer phase von 45
jahren die da ist in die verschiedensten
richtungen gehen richtung kommunismus in
italien julius ebola richtung faschismus
richtung konstruktivismus richtungs zu
realismus also hin wieder in diese
perspektiven die sich wieder auf ein
zentrum berufen von dem aus die welt
sich ordnet während ein paar tapfere
aufrechte frau aus man beispielsweise
tristan tzara die blieben in diesem
konstrukt des vorläufigen aber haben wir
stellen kann und sich vielleicht nicht
doch eine zu große leerstelle
geschafften gewissen wenn wir wissen
dass hugo ball ich weiß nicht zwei drei
jahre nach diesem tollen auftritt geht
er zurück war vorher katholisch wird
wieder soja katholischer und schreibt
selbst geht zurück auf den monty wie
rita und zu den scharf blöden mehr natur
menschen zu den schlaf blöden dem fehlte
das und dann werde einfach wieder
katholisch
ich würde die formulierung der wird er
einfach wieder katholik die würde ich
bestreiten wollen weil man kann
natürlich diesen durchbruch zur
unmittelbaren wirklichkeit und bei coop
alles das exemplarisch auch als eine
form von mystischen sehnen nach einem an
einer unmittelbaren präsenz nach einer
unmittelbaren einheit mit der
wirklichkeit deuten und es ist ganz
interessant dass gerade in diesem
zeitraum hugo ball aber auch philosophen
wie wittgenstein philosophen walter
benjamin 1916 genau diese mystische
erfahrung am rande der sprache suchten
das heißt die idee dass man sich
beispielsweise in religiöse oder auch in
gewisse sprach philosophische systeme
einfindet das kann auch dazu führen dass
man eben diesen mystischen direkt
kontakt sucht indem man am rande der
sprache
operiert und ich würde hugo ball schon
als jemanden sehen der der nicht nur
eine kindische sprache schafft sondern
auch eine mystische sprache nach der
unmittelbarkeit der dinge suchte ich
weiß nicht ob sie sich für die waren
dabei ist jene reklamieren die es
schafften bis zum ende ihres lebens
diesen sein tanz auf einem schaukelnden
band durchzuhalten waren aber aber ist
ärger gibt es ein paar ja es könnte auch
heißen dass eben die bekannten systeme
auch der katholizismus auch die jährige
auch nicht blöder sind oder so wenn man
das dass der mensch gewisse menschen
jedenfalls dann das auch nein sie stehen
mit den mit denen die bis zum wechsel
hat ihn seine krücken aber der zusammen
trost funktion so sind bergen auch die
kunst auch vielleicht eine
boost-funktion die art von kunst die
vorher war aber nicht die art von tools
die dabei propagierte der ausdruck einer
haltung war die mit dem unsicheren
gearbeitet hat mit dem widersprüchlichen
mit dem unsinnigen mit dem gegen
zinedine mit dem mit dem permanent
changierenden und oszillierenden und das
ist das existenziell spannendere aber
natürlich auch energiereich man muss
natürlich sagen wenn wir von der neuen
figur sprechender name antwortet auf
einer herrschen der rede
das heißt eine welt voller nach und kann
es nicht geben er vielleicht leben wir
gerade in dieser welt voller nachhinein
dem es gar keine sinnvollen widerstand
ergibt das heißt wenn alle nur noch
närrisches erzeugt aber natürlich ist
die funktion von da nur sinnvoll wenn es
herrschen die ideologien überhaupt gibt
die rena rische rede ist immer eine
reaktive sie kann nie selbst produktiv
werden da lief um sie mir eine brücke zu
einem kleinen fast dabei ist die
experimente dass ich mit ihnen kurz
machen möchte eine schweizer literatur
experte in seinem artikel zu 100 jahre
da macht einen interessanten querverweis
verweist darauf dass über sieben
jahrzehnte nachdem anfang im cabaret
voltaire in der schweiz eine
dadaistische aktion die er meint total
empörung ausgelöst hat war 1980
jugendbewegung in zürich gibt eine
fernsehsendung ch magazin wurde
diskutiert
lösung dass die alten und die jungen
sich finden da haben sich zwei
jugendliche eingeschlichen in die
sendung als und strenge bürger
verkleidet beunruhigt die bürger und
fordern jetzt drastische wirklich
drastische ruhe und ordnung schritte
gegen die jungen das möchte ich ihnen
kurzzeitig konnte grammer haft die sache
nun aber verstört sie die hand gedrückt
wirklich nur abgeschlagen
sie hätten die hand die straße und
abschlag die politik würde sie
geschlagen haug aber nicht werden wirkt
wie schlange hier bei uns jetzt nicht
lösen wenn sie jetzt sieht herr dann war
der lage werde dann lasse ich ihnen dazu
ich finde das unerhört was ich wie beide
wird das ganze gespräch beherrscht und
als als der vorgang folge sprach mit
platz garantieren
demonstrationen waren wieder bei mir
kommen was passiert ist und
wohngemeinschaften weil immer hier zu
einer demonstration wird immer stark
sein viel oder wenig demonstrationen
es darf kein augenlicht station mit
oracle das bündnis aber kazak ein schild
mit dem was jetzt dafür zelten denn sie
mit dem attribut das 18 20 verzeichnet
nur das irgendwie sieht optisch
verbreitert damit wäre die zweite
ablaufen
ich danke ihnen für ihre weise handstand
dialog bitte ich danke den mann an der
spitze
ja die sache endet in der verzweiflung
eigentlich das war emilie lieberherr
eine bake aufrechte sozialdemokraten die
dazu ständig man in der stadt ist das
dadaismus in aktion hier
alles um zu drehen bis niemand mehr
versteht was ernst und was nicht ist
fällt mir die selbstironie wie breit das
sind so aufrecht reiner schöne eigenen
pop kann ich gut nachvollziehen aber das
ist ich glaube nichts besonders
ungewöhnlich ist das fand man im klub
2013 permanent das teil der politischen
das ist noch nicht das was sie zum 30
selbstironie das spontane dass das
imaginäre das mystische dass sein
tanzende das projizieren denn das dass
gauck in das klingt das schaut kinder
das dass das chaotische dabei dass sich
auf keinen boden festlegen wollen
sondern sondern diese figur des gauklers
und schaut hat es ja ganz wichtig weil
da da ist ja nicht der begriffe das
schaukelpferd und das ist natürlich eine
permanente witt bewegungen der mann gar
keine stabilität sucht und auch keine
stabilität hat von der man arbeiten kann
und das ist eine kippbewegung die
besonders schwer zu finden ist aber sie
können natürlich bei fritz teufel jetzt
in der studentenbewegung 68 69 sind in
deutschland nicht jeder der eine
talkshow geht und irgendwie interveniert
ist david gleichen da da ist aber die da
ist machen das natürlich exemplarisch
damals getan aber man sollte das konzept
vielleicht auch nicht über denen in dem
man jede intervention zum dadaismus
erklärt aber was da drinnen vordergrund
gerückt hat war die utopie des humanen
und dass diese utopie des humanen nicht
realisierbar ist das zeigt auch dieses
titelbild das ist letztlich dann auf den
kopf gefallen der kopf ist zwar weg aber
man kann mit den beinen in der luft
herum wirbeln die utopie des humanen ist
aber auch in der heutigen gesellschaft
die die idee des individuums denn da da
ist zu einem großen teil verdankt auch
den freiraum des individuellen die aber
heute nur quasi wie eine litfaßsäule ist
auf der alles mögliche darauf projiziert
ist heute ist die frage wo ist der lokus
kommunist wo ist der gemeinsame boden wo
ist der gemeinplatz der common ground
auf dem wir uns alle befinden was unsere
heutige moral was ist unsere heutige
ethik auch da ist das humane letztlich
nicht realisiert
in dieser aber rein von der form her
würde man ist unsagbar sorgten vor
vermuten ist einiges geblieben das
möchte ich zum schluss auch noch kurz
zeigen wie der film den sie dann nachher
sehen können ganz und es lohnt sich
übergänge anspricht aber ich wundere
mich ob sie da einverstanden sind aber
sagt vieles aus dem dadaismus ich sie
übergeschwappt in unsere moderne kultur
und lebenswelt hier und zwar zeigt der
film das so
[Musik]
man erkennt in jeder großen bewegung des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts steckt ein
moment von man hat wirklich nichts
radikaler ist gemacht
ob performance oder polit kunst viele
moderne kunstformen wurzeln in katar
[Musik]
da hat sie kunst im klassischen
akademischen sind kaputt gemacht da der
hat initialen gesten gemacht das heißt
dinge zum ersten mal gemacht die vorher
in der kunst nicht möglich waren
und wenn man sie nachher in der kunst
macht sind sie immer schon einmal
passiert
[Musik]
da da findet sich auch in der popkultur
angefangen bei magazin und plattencovers
bis hin zu musik videos
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zum schluss in den fünf minuten wir uns
bleiben ist lady gaga irgendwie da da
oder da fehlt das wichtigste da fällt es
wichtig sind also da fällt die haltung
dahinter aber es ist natürlich in einem
weitaus größeren maß ist da noch in
unseren kunstformen aufgenommen das
absurde theater wurde vom tristan tzara
gemacht die modernes ballett bis pina
bausch komplett nieder da eine bühne
geboten hat die schnitttechniken von
videoclips die wurden bereits und
wikinger gelingt und gerhard richter
damals gemacht oder von rinne klar all
diese geschichten also das ist einem war
in einem unerhörten ausmaß eigentlich in
unserer kunstproduktion aufgegangen die
nicht nur kunstproduktion ist und quasi
unsere lebenswelt ästhetisch fort ohne
dass aber das bewusstsein noch da ist
dass das auf dauer zurückgeht und vor
allen dingen was mich völlig erstaunt
dass bei diesem jubiläum da der eines
völlig vergessen wird nämlich dass kein
mensch mehr da ist es literatur ist dass
die verkaufszahlen von der touristischen
billion kreis zeit seit zwei jahrzehnten
relaxen
das werk baut sich lohmann sollte es
lesen es steht noch viel gescheites drin
würde ich schon zu meinen einfluss von
dada und auch die collagen technik sieht
muss natürlich auch sagen das medium des
films das damals aufgaben und heute das
master medium ist kulturell ist
natürlich sehr da darf ihn auch die
ganzen computermanipulationen das ist
natürlich innerhalb der logik von da an
ein volltreffer
das heißt das medium kann da jetzt auch
entgegen dass das medium des digitalen
das medium des films aber was man
natürlich an beispielen wie lady gaga
oder auch positiv sehen ist wie schwer
es ist die kommunizieren die vermarktung
die ding wertung zu vermeiden und jetzt
gerade beispiele wie lady gaga oder post
riot das sind natürlich dinge die von
der marktlogik sofort vereinnahmt werden
und dann nicht mehr die funktion
erfüllen können die da hatte und
deswegen war es auch ein großes glück
für data dass es so kurz nur gedauert
hat und hätte man das auch nicht
vermeiden können um den bogen zu
schließen möchte ich zum schluss noch
ganz kurz ergründen wie viel dadaismus
in diesen bekannten philosophen und die
diesen bekannten schriftsteller steckt
wolfram
berger ist ein dadaistischer philosophen
nicht eine kontradiktion injektor eine
ein widersinn weil ein philosoph braucht
ein system
nein es gibt sehr viele philosophen die
eben anti philosophen sind anti
strukturen haben die die philosophischen
systeme die gewirkt sind die engel fäden
haben einfach aufdröseln und wieder ein
neubeginn ermöglichen sokrates war so
ein philosoph erasmus von rotterdam war
so ein philosoph der züricher
wissenschafts philosoph paul feyerabend
ist zweifellos das heißt ich glaube wir
müssen philosophie immer in der spannung
zwischen systematiker und da da ist
neben sinne von anti systematiker sehen
die gäste machen
ihr habt euer system aber hier ist die
wirklichkeit und ich möchte noch mal
ganz anders aussehen insofern würde ich
sagen da ist sicher erkenntnistheorie
philosophie die ist sehr wichtig und die
gab es schon immer und sie in ein
bisschen zu der ich glaube dass eine
sehr wichtige haltung dies erreicht
heute sogar noch wichtiger als vor 10
oder 15 jahren rausschaut bei ihnen
haben unsere recherchen ergeben dass sie
vielleicht sogar noch ein stark
praktizierender da ist bis heute in
ihrem schönen wunderbar neuen buch die
kunst an nichts zu glauben kommt am
anfang der eindruck auf sie hätten den
rabbiner in einer bibliothek an
dokumenten aus früheren jahrhunderten
gefunden was ganz tolle dinge sagt und
mit der zeit habe ich das gefühl dass
existiert gar nichts also führung kam
sie beim schreiben
nein nein es ist nicht ein funken es ist
das bewusstsein dass zum einen und es
geht um eine atheistische manifest mit
dem namen manuale telesis tänzer
transistoren das aber eigentlich nur
atheistische literatur aus den letzten
jahrhunderten versammelt und sentenzen
zum leben im hier und jetzt in den
vordergrund stellen aber das was beides
ist ich habe jetzt diesen weg ist jetzt
aber aber der punkt der mich mit da da
verbinden weil dabei wirklich die schule
die literarische schule war mit groß
geworden bin
zum einen die existenzialistische
haltung nicht darin verkörpert sah und
immer noch sehr und zu machen dass das
bewusstsein dass literatur und kunst
fiktion ist eine gut gebaute gut
konstruierte aber fiktion und ob ich
jetzt das buch schreibe oder das buch
unter anderem zu schreiben
macht nur klarer dass die kunst an
nichts zu glauben sehr sehr schweres
denn selbst wenn man das nicht glaubt
glaubt man an etwas und man kann aber
auch nicht an nichts glauben weil wir
alle an etwas glauben nur sich dessen
bewusst zu sein dass das woran man
glaubt eine fiktion ist eine
konstruktion ist und dass alle wahrheit
in diesem bemühen liegt eine mauer vor
dem aufgrund aufzubauen an der wir uns
festhalten können im bewusstsein dass
sie irgendwann einstürzen wird weil
nichts hält es keinen soliden untergrund
gibt das chaotische so sehr präsent ist
wie das biologische das rationale wie
das irrationale all das ist der geist
von da dann bin ich nach wie vor
verkörpert er aber immer wieder andere
private ausdrucksformen und ist dass
auch dieser geister in die freiheit zu
geben scheint in ihrer biografie mal
sind sie in sao paulo geboren und dann
wieder nicht das gibt freiheit auch also
das war eine höfliche form den
journalisten damals zu sorgen wissen sie
wenn sie wissen wollen wer mein vater
und wer meine mutter ist also ich
schreibe bücher alles an weil das
privateste ist das private und literatur
seine ausdrucksform davon die schon
privat und öfen haben dann haben sie
einfach eine geschichte erzählt ich weiß
der job des schriftsteller sie sind ja
auch zweieiige zwillinge vielleicht
haben wir das wollte ich nicht eigens
erwähnen dass sich jeder letzte frage
haben den philosophen hier weil
frauenberger darf auch der philosoph mal
in fluss kommen
oder versteht die wahrheit keinen spaß
ein utopischer philosoph lang hat immer
erzählt eine welt die es nicht gibt auch
die ville philosophie ist voll von
führungs zonen und gerade dort wo sie
handlungsleitend werden sind das
fiktionen also denken sie am plateau
stadt das ist ein idealer start der
existiert nur antworten aber erleichtert
unser handeln
deswegen ein philosoph der keine
fiktionalen kräfte hat ist gar keiner
meine herren es war faszinierend mit
ihnen über sinn und unsinn und sinn im
unsinn zu sprechen herzlich er ist zwei
tage früher geboren
dann gehen alles ist geklärt herzlichen
dank gleich im anschluss folgt wie
erwähnt an der sehenswerte film das
prinzip da der viele bilder liefert zu
den klugen gedanken meinen arbeiten
gäste eben und wenn sie dann noch die
verein tauchen wollen in den data
kursmustern besuchen sie doch das erste
online dem museum in unserem
interaktiven web dokumentations- shop da
da da dam und nächste woche sprechen wir
hier mit jon kabat zinn über achtsamkeit
als schlüssel zu einem gelingenden leben
da das war's danke und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]
da